today's episode is brought to you by -
lien try - lane for free on your first
device and when you decide to upgrade to
premium use my channel code biographic
Stu get a discount of 10% more on them
in a bit what do you think of when you
think of Pirates do you conjure up
images of fearless sea dwellers cruising
the high seas perhaps you think of the
more violent realities to ships locked
side by side their cruise crossing
swords their captains dueling to the
death maybe you even imagine the
ungroomed pirate he's been marooned on
an island biding his time before he
unleashes a bold escape plan how long
before you think of Blackbeard of
Captain Kidd black Bart Roberts Johnny
Depp
those men were fearsome exceptional
pirates except for the latter who used
overlooked intelligence Farrell charm to
rob the Caribbean blind during the
height of all piracy history has made
them exemplars of the Golden Age of
piracy beyond the top rate pirates
somewhere on down the line that's where
your finds the English man born under
the name John Rackham immortalized by
his pirate Monica Calico Jack
[Music]
the Golden Age of piracy was well
underway when our protagonist mr.
Rackham first appeared in another man's
spyglass this was the Classical Age of
pirates where scallywag sailed the seven
seas and robbed the rich coffers of
Spanish French and English ships and
colonies they lasted around eighty years
roughly from 1650 to 1730 every great
epoch needs a cultural center runs for
the Pirates
that was nacelle decades before loyalist
settlers escaped the American Revolution
by fleeing to the Bahamas
Nassau became an overnight pirate Haven
with rogues of all kinds fleeing
unfriendly ports to congregate on one
massive pirate friendly Island even
though it only became a pirate port
around 1715 just a few short years
before the end of the age Nassau would
represent the pirate Way of life better
than any other ship Cove or Port Pirates
were curious lot they spent their days
relieving hard-working merchants of
their wares and
they wasted their nights trying to drink
all the rum in the western hemisphere
you'd be forgiven for thinking that
these brigands and rogues were just
Carribean Vikings with bigger ships and
curvy swords but in between all the
violence and swashbuckling pirates could
be surprisingly progressive many of the
Pirates that sat anchor off Nassau were
once soldiers or merchants for one crown
or another and the system chewed them up
and spit them out they were
decommissioned unprotected otherwise
abandoned by their government so they
turned to a way of life that promised
independence and self-sufficiency if
nothing else now and the crews that
operated there became something of a
strange democracy where men who were
committed to the Pirates
anti-establishment code always had a
place to stay and a voice to share in
the early 18th century the voices that
carried the loudest were often from men
whose names survived the ensuing
centuries Charles vane Samuel Bellamy
Benjamin hornigold Edward England John
Rackham was not one of these men he was
a b-list pirate at best working as the
quartermaster for Charles vanes crew
Rackham talked a big game as many
pirates may have done at the time but
the reality is that he begins our story
has only a left hands on a far more
prominent pirate ship
despite his lowly status relative to the
other infamous pirates of the time
Rackham and his peers were enjoying the
absolute heights of the Golden Age of
piracy Nassau was a pure paradise
centrally located hideouts that made it
easy for veins accomplished crew to
escape out to sea Rob a few ships and
then hightail it back to their bohemian
base the island itself was heavily
fortified thanks to natural features and
man-made defences making it nearly
impossible for individual pirate hunters
or Navy ships to chase down pirates that
went to ground there once on the islands
a thriving pirate community offered all
the food rum and women that a pirate
could ever ask for
there was a never-ending party thrown by
pirates and enjoyed by pirates there
were no laws no rules and opportunities
for plunder were all around I mean what
could possibly go wrong for the first 15
years of the 18th century nearly all of
Europe was enraptured
in the war of Spanish Succession most of
the great powers of Western and Central
Europe had some sort of claim to the
Spanish throne after the death of
charles ii in 1700 and the continent
spends a decade and a half sorting out
the ensuing conflicts by the time it was
over pirates had complete commands of
the Caribbean and were engaging in all
sorts of shameless pirate ory behavior
with impunity when King George the first
realized that something had to be done
to end the piracy he issued the
proclamation for suppressing pirates on
September the 5th 1717 all pirates had
one year to turn themselves into a
colonial governor and receive complete
clemency for all past actions no tricks
no traps pirates could end their
pirating and take up a normal life with
a normal trade burn age often marked by
near absolute and monarchical power it
was a pretty sweet deal for a bunch of
dirty commoners it may have even been a
tacit admission from the king that the
government could have acted better or
provided better for those who'd felt a
pirate's life was their only real hope
for a healthy life the king's pardon as
it would come to be known in Nassau
deeply divided the pirate Republic some
felt that the English crown prioritizing
the ends of piracy surely meant that the
party was over a few may have even
wanted to take those Democratic pirate
principles and try to build a real
country but the most vocal group were
the pure pirates who declared dead never
bow to the Crown Rackham ins the rest of
vanes crew were squarely in the latter
camp so when George sent former
privateer Woodes Rogers to clean up now
and ends the party once and for all
vane and Rackham felt obliged to welcome
the would-be governor with a pirates
greeting in July of 1718 vane arranged
for a small group of ships to set anchor
off the islands and fire at Rogers
incoming frigate he also set a ship on
fire and sailed it directly at Rogers in
the hope of destroying his retinue in a
slightly more theatrical way
Rogers ultimately survived the attack
while Rackham and his crew escaped out
to sea amid the chaos vane and rack and
spent the next four months terrorizing
the sow Jamaica and other nearby islands
while Roger slowly convinced pirates to
accept the Kings pardon
quartermaster John Rackham was
coordinating more attacks than ever
before and so it was that our
protagonist Jack came to his first real
spot of trouble in November of 1718 four
months after vane tried to blow up
Rogers ship and two months after the
deadline for the Kings pardon John
Rackham and his war mongering friends
set their sights on a magnificent new
prize this was a French warship almost
certainly filled to the brim with rum
raw materials sugar tobacco and who
knows what else
Rackham and his friends badly wanted to
take it for themselves captain vane gave
the order to engage but he quickly
realized the Pirates were out guns and
their ships superior speed would not be
enough to best the warship vane wanted
to retreat and live to fight another day
an idea that his bloodthirsty crew was
appalled by it was a no-win situation
for the veteran captain he could face
immediate death by fighting a hopeless
battle against a massive warship or face
a potential mutiny by upsetting his
increasingly violent crew then was in
command at least for the moment so he
ordered an
kela retreats bus after the pirates had
safely escaped the French ship the crew
of 70 were predictably mad at the lack
of a score ever the democracy veins
Pirates took a vote and the vast
majority of them were ready for a change
in leadership
Charles vane and his band of supporters
were given a small schooner they had
captured days before and they were sent
away in his place the crew elected a new
man one who appeared more capable of
delivering the mayhem and bloody piracy
that the crew was searching for and that
would be Calico Jack Rackham now you
might not have to worry about pirates
stealing your plunder but you might have
to worry about people online trying to
steal your passwords and data but good
news - Lane is a one-stop shop for all
of your digital identity protection
needs now if all of your passwords are
the same that's a bad idea
you can use - Lane's password manager to
create and securely store complex and
unique passwords making it less likely
that your accounts are gonna get
compromised they also have a VPN as part
of their service meaning you can browse
the Internet securely and confidently
even on public Wi-Fi but it's not just
that they also actively monitor the dark
web to see if your information has been
leaked somewhere that means that if it
has you can go in and easily change your
passwords for other services before
someone breaks into those accounts as
well plus - link does what it's always
done it stores your passwords it keeps
your personal data secure it fills all
of those annoying boxes for payment info
or passwords for you
so make your life easier head to - Lane
comm forward slash buyer graphics and
you'll get to try - Lane for free on
your first device and we need to submit
you want to upgrade to premium use my
code via graphics and you'll get 10% off
that premium membership and let's get
back to the video
[Music]
many a pirate that sailed through the
Caribbean developed some sort of
nickname ins newly minted pirate Captain
John Rackham was no exception Rackham
had a habit of wearing eye catching
clothing made from colorful Indian
calico cloth
thus Calico Jack was born on the high
seas unfortunately it didn't take long
for Rackham to realize he made a much
better quartermaster than needed a
captain it was easy to advocate for bold
plans and violent delights as a crew
member but calico Jack's soon found that
designing and executing glorious pirate
plans was a lot harder than it looked
like a modern-day politician who regrets
the promises he made on the way to the
election calico Jack's suddenly had to
provide all the plundering that his
peers had demanded from vane what's more
he had to do it well governor Woodes
Rogers began executing pirates and
cleaning up the region wreckin started
small targeting low-rent merchants or
undefended coastline he found modest
success and even executed a crafty plan
that made it into the pages of Captain
Charles Johnson's a general history of
pirates according to Johnson Calico Jack
and crew had parked their sloop off the
coast of Cuba and a few men had gone
ashore to resupply the ship with fresh
food rum and ammunition at low tide as
the Sun was setting a Spanish gunship
responsible for patrolling the Cuban
coastline had sailed into view and
spotted the Pirates this was a powerful
ship that already had a captured English
asleep in tow the Spanish couldn't mount
a proper attack low tide so they decided
to wait until morning then attack the
Pirates at first light Calico Jack and
his crew spotted the Spanish warship and
devised a plan rather than try to escape
from the port at low tide Rackham
ordered the ship abandoned and everyone
fled to shore as the Spanish ship fired
on the pirate sloop at daybreak the
Pirates snuck aboard the captured
English sloop incapacitated the guards
and sailed away before the frigate could
realize what had happened it was a nifty
move and one that locally marked the
high point of Rackham's tenure as a
pirate captain the captain Jack had just
as many setbacks as he did successes in
December of 1718 for example he targeted
a large merchant ship called Kingston
for
session but draw the lousy plan that
almost got him and his crew killed or a
cam lied to the Kingston because it was
carrying a hugely valuable cargo but he
didn't want to seize the ship at a
tactically isolated area instead the
crew jumped aboard within sight of
Jamaica's Port Royal where the Pirates
could easily be identified and tracked
by the ship's merchants they hired
bounty hunters who caught up with a ship
several weeks later at isla de la piñas
off the western coast of Cuba historians
are unsure what happens next some
reports that Calico Jack and his crew
had all gone to lands and passed out
drunk leaving their conquest undefended
and the looter still aboard
other versions suggests that Jack was a
coward opting to hide in the woods
rather than fight the hunters either way
Rackham was in no position to do
anything about it and he quickly lost
his best capture before he had the
chance to make any money off the score
Calico Jack wasn't disciplines enough to
consistently pull off successful pirate
heists and he wasn't foolhardy enough to
launch blind attacks and let the
doubloons fall where they may
so a few months after overthrowing his
captain and living large at sea Rackham
and his crew decided to give up return
to Nassau and try to convince governor
Rogers to extend them a pardon months
after the Kings deadline upon landing at
the South Rackham on his crew were bound
and taken before Rogers we're Calico
Jack informed him that deposed captain
Charles vane was the real enemy here you
see none of them actually wanted to be
pirates but vane had pressed them into
service forcing them to rob rape and
ransack every village in the West Indies
once wholesome John Rackham that led a
successful mutiny against vane those
good-hearted pirates they had sailed
straight back to Nassau hoping to return
to normal productive lives and the
English crown it was quite accidentally
a completely brilliant plan governor
Rogers had never forgiven vane for the
far ship stunt upon his arrival and had
continued to hold a grudge against him
so in 1719 Rogers officially pardoned
Calico Jack and his crew and they all
settled down to live a clean decent life
free of piracy
for all we know John Rackham genuinely
did mean to give up his life on the lam
when he returns Anna saw and accepted
Woodes Rogers pardon
however Rackham hadn't accounted for the
one variable that can make a man do just
about anything it wasn't long back on
lands before our former pirate captain
ran into a ravishing redhead woman in a
bohemian pub and bonny was an Irish lass
that immediately captured racoons
attention that he had instant chemistry
and were immediately smitten with each
other as Rackham settled back into
civilian life he wanted to take Annie as
his wife to have and to hold as they
lived now to their days in the Sun and
on the sands there was just one problem
though
Anne was already married and must have
had a type because her husband was also
a former pirate named John John bonny
had happily taken the pardon and
accepted a new job working directly for
governor Rogers as an informants on
pirate activity in short he was a snitch
helping Rogers bring the remaining
Pirates of the Caribbean to justice
Rackham and Anne Bonny who tried
everything they could think of in order
to start a new life together
they pleaded directly to John bonny with
Anne declaring her love for another man
when he said no they took their case to
Rogers asking that he consider annulling
the marriage as provincial governor and
John Bonnie's boss in a proposal that's
both sweet and sexist Rackham even
suggested divorce of our purchase as an
option offering to buy and from John
Bonnie but nothing worked we've no other
options available to them Calico Jack
and his lover and Bonnie decided a
pirate's life was their last recourse so
in August of 1720 jock Anne and a few
other friendly ex-pirate stole a ship
from Nassau Harbor and returned to the
sea Anne Bonny may very well be the
reason we remember Calico Jack at all
many sailors at the time believed that
having a woman aboard a ship was bad
luck even well-respected pirates like
Blackbeard wouldn't allow them on the
ship let alone take up arms alongside
one successful female pirates were
awfully rare even during the Golden Age
of piracy which explains why some
sources report that and may have hidden
her agenda from everyone but
lover and co-captain during calico
Jack's second drawer of pirate duty some
records seem to indicate that it was
Anne who was both the brains and the
Brawn of the operation years of living
through a bad marriage had given her an
edge which she unleashed by season
dozens of ships and killing any captives
who might threaten to undermine the
operation or rat them out to the
provincial governor all there's plenty
of Legends that have raised up around
and bonny the pirate lass including the
time she tricked a French crew into
surrendering by standing over a bloodied
mannequin with a raised axe rack and by
contrast was mostly enjoying the sex and
partying that a piracy lifestyle
afforded him he enjoyed his new life
with an unencumbered by the burdens of
proper civilization and it often invites
sailors from captured ships to drink
with him
some even stayed on as new crew members
one such sailor who joined calico Jack's
entourage was yet another woman in
disguise Mary Reed and Mary became fast
friends with each seeing through the
other's disguise both were elated to
find some female companionship on the
open ocean and began confiding in each
other and it is that might as well have
been pulled straight from Twelfth Night
Calico Jack began to grow jealous of the
gabbie lad who and was suddenly spending
so much time with eventually Anne had to
COO a man in on Mary secrets and for the
rest of their days at sea the fearsome
threesome carried out raids and thefts
with no one else realizing that two of
the Caribbeans fiercest remaining
pirates were hiding breasts under their
copse
[Music]
unfortunately for Anne Mary Anne Calico
Jack their adventures at sea wouldn't
last more than a few months leaving a
relatively calm life to become a pirate
would be dangerous for anyone leaving
your pirate snitch husband absconding
with a former pirate integrase of Lee
robbing every merchant ship from Mexico
to the Florida Keys well that's
practically suicidal it took all of one
month for governor Woodes Rogers to
announce a bounty for Calico Jack and
Bonnie and their crew and another month
after that before bounty hunters were
hot on their trail the walls were
closing around John Rackham ins there
would be no clever lie to save him this
time around it was only a matter of time
before the pirate hunters caught up to
them which is precise
what happens in the final weeks of 1720
hunters led by captain Jonathan Barnett
bordered the ship meaning to bring
everyone abroad back to Jamaica to be
tried for piracy Mary NN mounted a
hellish boisterous defense of the
Pirates but eventually they were
outnumbered
once again accounts differ here some say
Calico Jack was too drunk below deck to
offer a proper defense while other
reports say he simply recognized he was
beaten and quietly laid down his arms
whatever the truth all the women of the
ship were prepared to fight until their
last breath John Rackham offered no
resistance he let himself be captured
and imprisoned without much resistance
as his reign and crew watched in horror
and disgust justice came swiftly for
Calico Jack and his crew Anne Bonny and
Mary read were spared from the gallows
as both were pregnant when captured but
the remaining crew including Rackham
were sentenced to hang
less than a month later in Port Roll
Jamaica before he died an allegedly
visited earl of iraq him in prison he
was overjoyed to see her one last time
she merely scoffed telling him that if
you had fought like a man you need not
have hanged like a dog he was hanged
just a few days later on November the
18th 1720 at the age of just 37 as with
many Pirates of their day Rackham's
corpse was hung on display as a warning
to other pirates the Jamaicans chose to
hang calico Jack's body on a small islet
outside of Port Royal a tiny piece of
land now known as Rackham ski as
probably fitting that John Rackham's
most lasting impact on the world around
him was a monument to his own failure
Calico Jack was not the brightest pirate
ever steer a schooner nor was he the
boldest in truth he was an imperfect
pirate who accomplished very little and
earned his fame primarily by the company
he kept he was outlived by Charles vane
his former mentor who eventually found
himself marooned on an island in the
aftermath of a hurricane
it was also outlived by his partner and
Bonnie who likely escaped from her
Jamaican prison and lived a full life
the prison has no record of Bonnie's
execution or release and as a result
most histories take that to mean that
she slinked away and lived a full life a
recorded death date is decades later in
the 1780s so Rackham didn't manage to
outlive most of his peers in the latter
portion of the Golden Age of piracy
he was never as
respected either and like black bears
and hornigold nearly always referenced
as the quintessential later of figures
with Rackham just sinking into the
background even as a pirate he fell
short his best prized the Kingston was
stolen back from him often there weeks
perhaps worst of all his reputation as a
pirate was blackened by too many
surrenders and too few fights he went to
his death disrespected by his former
crew and confidants Captain Jack was
indeed one of the worst pirates you've
ever heard of but if he were here to
defend himself today he might just point
out that you have in fact heard of him
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe also check out our
fantastic sponsor dashlane who are
linked to below thank you for watching
[Music]